alors on revient sur ces annonces
évidemment sur la la situation sur place
avec Armelle charrier bonjour Armel
bonjour Elisabeth on a assisté hier
finalement à une série d'annonces quand
même assez surprenante côté rue s'il y a
cet appel au repli il y a aussi cette
cette annonce celle de la mort d'un d'un
haut-responsable poreuse de Carson
décédé dans des conditions assez
troubles on suspecte un assassinat
qu'est-ce qui se passe exactement alors
là sur la ville de Kerson on a eu des
semaines où on avait quasiment pas
d'informations et quand il y a pas
d'informations ce qui se passe quelque
chose en règle générale parce que les
Ukrainiens n'aiment pas qu'on précise ce
qu'ils font alors ils aiment pas par
rapport au russe et au risque que ça
peut encourir en même temps parce que ça
leur donne aussi une limite du coup ils
sont assez libres de faire ce qu'ils
veulent et puis de l'autre côté les
Russes avaient commencé à dire qu'il
voulait évacuer du personnel civil on se
souvient de ça et on avait cette
situation qui est effectivement
complètement gelée et
avec un moment donné particulier qui est
l'hiver qui va arriver on sait que la
période là c'est tout ce que la période
de la raspottina donc c'était celle où
il y a le plus debout donc les choses
sont compliquées à mettre en place à ce
moment là et en hiver à la limite dans
ces pays-là on sait qu'on va battre
parce que il va y avoir de la glace il
va y avoir de la neige et que ce soit
les Ukrainiens ou que ce soit les Russes
ce sont des gens qui savent combattre
dans ces conditions-là alors ils le font
plus facilement au printemps enfin on
était quand les choses sont sèches mais
ils savent le faire pendant l'hiver et
donc on est sur une guerre de position
et on voit clairement que les uns et les
autres veulent tirer bénéfices en fait
juste avant l'hiver ce qui va se passer
personne a surpris parce que l'annonce
effectivement russe de dire et bien
écoutez on s'en va et c'est un peu
inattendu on avait commencé à entendre
des déploiements de l'autre côté du
flevenière mais on n'avait pas une
vision exacte de ce qu'ils allaient
faire du coup les
Ukrainiens on le voit elle le répète
vont rester extrêmement prudent pour le
moment il n'avance pas en tout cas la
vigilance reste de mise qu'est-ce qui
redoutait redoute le guetaban le piège
c'est crédible ça ça reste crédible oui
alors il redoute plusieurs choses soit
vous vous retrouvez avec des Russes qui
annoncent qu'ils s'en vont et puis qui
finalement ne s'en vont pas ou pas
complètement et que donc du coup ils
arrivent dans des endroits qui peuvent
être minés par exemple il y a pour le
moment aucun signe de repli hein ça il
faut le dire il y a commence il y a eu
une partie de repli qui a été annoncée
c'est à dire que lorsque les Russes ont
précisé qu'ils allaient faire ce repli
ils ont commencé à évacuer du matériel
lourd donc ça leur matériel lourd on l'a
vu partir et on a vu aussi qu'il y avait
eu des installations qui avaient mises
en place comme des antennes relais par
exemple ou des ponts ou des choses comme
ça qu'il détruisaient donc il y a des
signes que du coup il y a une volonté de
partir et surtout il y a une logique qui
est qu'ils ont enlevé le personnel civil
la population civile est partie elle est
partie soit parce qu'elle l'a choisi et
qu'elle est partie côté russe avec les
Russes soit parce qu'elle ne l'a pas
choisi et qu'elle a
vous subissent que les Russes ont
demandé mais la population elle est
partie dans ces conditions là si vous
regardez vous avez du coup une bataille
qui peut se mettre en place c'est-à-dire
que vous allez avoir d'un côté les
Russes qui partent de d'un côté du
fleuve et les Ukrainiens seront de
l'autre côté le fleuve c'est un énorme
fleuve c'est pas une rivière c'est
vraiment un fleuve donc ça veut dire que
s'il doit y avoir une bataille militaire
elle sera violente parce qu'à partir du
moment donné où les Russes sont évacués
la population civile en termes de droit
de la guerre on est sur une bataille
donc dans ces cas-là on est entre
militaires donc ça veut dire qu'il peut
y avoir des bombardements il peut y
avoir des tirs ce que redoute en plus
les Ukrainiens c'est que la zone dans
laquelle les yeux russes sera parti sera
tout à fait piégée c'est à dire que
derrière on laisse effectivement des
mines antipersonnelles on laisse des
explosifs et que derrière il peut aussi
avoir un mouvement ou dans ces cas-là on
attire l'attention à Carson et puis il
va se passer quelque chose d'autre à
barmouth ou à carquis vous savez qu'on a
quand même une ligne de 1000 km avec
trois Macron en ce moment donc personne
est une zone c'est vrai que si on
regarde avec beaucoup d'attention Carson
c'est parce que c'était une zone
stratégique pour les Russes il y avait
amené un équipement qui est important
ils ont amené des soldats qui sont eux
très compétents ils avaient envoyé les
unités aéroportées parachutistes qui eux
sont parfaitement formés savent
parfaitement combattre et on avait vu
qu'ils avaient rafraîchi en envoyant des
gens juste mobilisées donc ça veut dire
qu'ils avaient mis des combattants neufs
frais qui étaient sur place et
évidemment en plus personne c'est la
ville stratégique parce que c'est celle
qui permet ensuite la route vers la
Crimée c'est celle qui permet aussi
d'avoir toute cette remontée vers le
nièpre qui touche effectivement tous les
endroits d'eau qui permet effectivement
ensuite d'approvisionner la Crimée et
qui remonte vers la centrale de zapporis
déjà donc tout ça fait dire que côté
militaire c'est tout à fait possible
parce qu'on comprend pourquoi est-ce
qu'on prépare une bataille pour l'hiver
mais en même temps ce sera à long terme
au détriment des Russes qui avaient
réussi à avoir une zone stratégique et
qui demain si doivent repasser le fleuve
ni être pour le regagner sur les
Ukrainiens ça la redemandra un effort
conséquent merci beaucoup Armelle pour
le